merci Laurence Cohen de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes sénatrice communiste du
Val-de-Marne Vice-Présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales et
vice-présidente de la délégation au
droit des femmes on va longuement parler
de la santé des femmes dans quelques
instants mais d'abord l'actualité c'est
toujours la réforme des retraites et la
PPL proposition de loi du groupe qui va
être examiné le 8 juin pour abroger la
réforme des retraites et Elisabeth borne
la juge en constitutionnelle car elle
alourdit les dépenses à l'appel chacun
la responsabilité n'a-t-elle pas raison
écoutez je pense que Elisabeth borne
devrait laisser le Conseil d'État à
statuer quand c'est un constitutionnel
ou pas selon leur interprétation et je
trouve surtout que le gouvernement
l'exécutif ne fait rien pour sortir par
le haut parce qu'il y a pas 50 solutions
c'est à dire que il n'écoute pas la rue
la rue c'est 5 mois de mobilisation avec
un front syndical uni et il balaya d'un
revers de main alors que ça fait cinq
mois que les manifestations sont
massives elles se déroulent dans le
calme et il y a une grande
responsabilité des syndicats ou alors
c'est le Parlement et on a vu comment le
Parlement a été traité puisque ça a été
à coup de 49,3 d'articles qui ont été
sortis de la Constitution et aujourd'hui
alors que il y a une PPL ce qui est tout
à fait dans le droit des parlementaires
et bien là encore mépris et elle va
aller chercher peut-être l'article 40
donc on voit bien qu'il y a un refus
absolument de discuter de cette loi qui
est une mauvaise loi qui est rejetée par
la majorité des Françaises et des
Français et son message après avoir
rencontré les syndicats et totalement
irresponsable c'est une loi qui à mon
sens est illégitime il faut l'abroger
elle est mauvaise et elle ne sert à rien
si ce n'est à faire travailler deux ans
de plus des gens qui déjà travaillé sont
usés et non pas envie de faire deux ans
de plus avec des salaires qui ne sont
pas à la hauteur elle ferait mieux de
s'occuper du de l'augmentation des
salaires qui est une revendication
générale des syndicats et que je
soutiens avec ma famille politique mais
là sur le fond est-ce qu'elle a pas
raison de dire que si
PPL de l'yote est adopté ça va coûter au
finances publiques ça va charger la
dépense publique mais écoutez il y a des
tas de moyens de financement d'ailleurs
dans la loi l'iode pardon il y a un
article qui ouvre la porte à d'autres
financements c'est ce que nous avons
essayé de dire dans le tout petit débat
la fenêtre d'ouverture qu'il y a eu au
niveau du Sénat mais elle n'en veut pas
moi je donne toujours cet exemple si on
arrêtait les exonérations de cotisations
patronales c'est 75 millions d'euros
donc vous voyez là il y a de quoi
largement
nourrir les caisses de sécurité sociale
pour vous la majorité va tout faire pour
empêcher à se débat de se tenir oui la
majorité va va tout faire pour empêcher
ce débat de de se tenir on voit bien là
qu'on a affaire à de l'autoritarisme à
vraiment une volonté politique de faire
taire tout ce qui est opposition c'est
un très mauvais calcul le président
Macron s'isole et l'exécutif en boîte le
pas notamment Elisabeth borne mais
est-ce que c'est pas un faux espoir
donné aux Français cette loi est-ce
qu'elle a vraiment une chance d'aboutir
d'arriver au bout écoutez le il y a une
question qui est posée c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait dans un pays quand on est à
la manœuvre comme les le gouvernement
avec une majorité relative quand c'est
rejeté et par la majorité des gens et
par les syndicats et par une opposition
politique qu'est-ce que l'on fait on
fait comme si de rien n'était c'est à
dire que Macron s'isole dans sa tour
d'ivoire et il n'entend pas les
revendications des Françaises et des
Français on nous dit mais oui ça a été
voté par le Sénat deux fois il y a une
commission de mixparitaire il y a eu un
accord entre députés sénateurs pour vous
le par le Parlement n'a pas pu bien se
prononcer le Parlement pour moi le texte
n'a pas été n'a pas été voté ni au
niveau de l'Assemblée nationale puisque
c'était à coup de 49,3 et au Sénat
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il s'est passé
une complicité entre LR et le
gouvernement pour pas passé ce texte
parce que effectivement avec
l'amendement ça varie chaque année nous
votions enfin pas nous nous votion
compte mais en tout cas il y avait un
majoritaire en faveur de cette prologue
de ce départ plus tardif à la retraite
donc c'est passé mais même elle a l'air
ils avaient fait des aménagements soit
disant pour adoucir les choses et ça ça
a été rocher par le gouvernement donc la
loi qui est sortie n'est pas la loi
voulue y compris par les LR donc elle
n'a pas été votée par le Parlement donc
c'est vraiment pour moi une faute
politique très grave et cette loi il
faut l'abroger et je pense que ce que
disent les syndicats aujourd'hui dans
l'unité c'est une belle leçon pour le
monde politique et qu'allez-vous faire
qu'avec la stratégie de la gauche au
Sénat puisque ce texte si toutefois il
est voté le 8 juin il va falloir qu'il
arrive au Sénat qu'elle va être la
stratégie de la gauche comment il va y
arriver bah écoutez la gauche va se
réunir pour voir comment on va faire au
niveau du Sénat il est clair qu'au
niveau du Sénat il y a une majorité de
droite qui partage cette cette réforme
du gouvernement donc il va une bataille
pour faire entendre nos arguments puis
je crois qu'il y a une petite musique
quand même qui est différente c'est à
dire qu'il y a beaucoup de mes collègues
qui sont renouvelés et je pense que
quand ils vont dans leur circonscription
ils se font tirer les oreilles par les
électrices et les électeurs qui leur
disent mais nous on veut pas de cette
loi-là alors est-ce qu'ils vont tenir
compte de leur électorat au niveau de
leur circonscriptions c'est un message à
Patrick cannelle président du groupe
socialiste les renouvelable il y a une
niche socialiste à la mi-juin vous leur
demandez de reprendre ce texte dans leur
niche moi écoutez je n'ai pas à demander
aux parties socialiste de reprendre
cette proposition de loi c'est un lieu
assez à eux de voir mais en tout cas
nous allons discuter ensemble au niveau
de la gauche pour se mettre d'accord
pour faire entendre cette voix là qui
est la voix de la raison abrogation de
la réforme on va parler de la santé des
femmes sujets importants sur lequel vous
avez travaillé notre journaliste Flora
sauvage a suivi vos travaux sont
reportage santé des femmes une inégalité
ignorée et diffusée vendredi à 16h30
elle vient nous en parler
[Musique]
bonjour Flora bonjour Oriane et Flora
tout d'abord pourquoi vous avez choisi
de vous intéresser à cette question de
la santé des femmes et bien on a choisi
la question de la santé des femmes parce
que la délégation des droits des femmes
que vous visez que vous la tête de
laquelle vous êtes vice-présidente a
décidé de travailler sur la question de
la santé des femmes et notamment la
santé des femmes au travail en fait on
matière de santé femmes et hommes ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne si les
femmes vivent plus longtemps elles
vivent souvent ou moins bonne santé
Laurence Cohen quand je vous ai
interrogé dans le cas du reportage vous
parlez d'une société patriarcale quelles
conséquence est-ce que ça a sur la santé
des femmes aujourd'hui en France mais
écoutez on est dans une société
patriarcale effectivement capitaliste et
patriarcal et moi je me bats contre ces
deux systèmes de domination et au niveau
de la santé des femmes ça a une
influence parce qu'il y a des
stéréotypes de genre qui font que on a
des idées reçues sur les maladies que
peuvent avoir les femmes et les hommes
par exemple toutes les maladies qui sont
cardiovasculaires vont être sous-estimés
chez les femmes et donc il va y avoir un
retard dans le diagnostic pour les
hommes ça va avoir aussi des
conséquences on considère par exemple
que
l'ostéoporose et n'est pas une maladie
masculine donc on va pas s'intéresser à
cette pathologie chez les hommes donc ce
retard de diagnostic chez les unes et
chez les autres font que on passe à côté
de pathologies ça peut être très grave
et on va y venir dans le détail sur les
mais juste un mot puisque dans ce
reportage vous dites je voyais bien que
vous avez choisi de vous intéresser à ce
sujet parce que je voyais bien qu'il y
avait des zones d'ombre sur la santé des
femmes quelles sont ces zones d'ombre
les zones d'ombres c'est un retard dans
le diagnostic parce qu'il y a un manque
de formation des professionnels
spécifiques au niveau justement santé et
genre et que au niveau du travail
également il y a des zones
d'invisibilité parce qu'on ne va pas
tenir compte de la précarité de la
pénibilité chez les femmes et on va
considérer de manière plus douce
si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi des troubles
musculo-squelettiques et on va ne pas
considérer par exemple les accidents du
travail alors que l'on sait que dans les
aides à domicile dans un certain nombre
de maladies donc du soin il va y avoir
pas mal d'accidents du travail même
c'est supérieur à ce qui se passe au
niveau du bâtiment mais on ne doit pas
prendre en considération ces troubles-là
de même qu'il va y avoir des zones
totalement invisibilisées je pense à la
ménopause par exemple qui est qui a des
conséquences au niveau des femmes au
travail je pense aussi aux violences
sexuelles et sexistes qui ne sont pas
prises en compte suffisamment il y a je
crois 80% à peu près des entreprises qui
n'ont pas de plan de prévention et on a
vu à la délégation aux droits des femmes
quand on a reçu notamment les
représentants du Medef combien il y
avait encore à travailler sur ces
questions là parce qu'il y avait une
sous-estimation et on avait l'impression
qu'on était demande de parallèle celui
des bisounours avec le Medef et puis
celui réel des syndicats et des
rapporteurs que nous sommes au niveau de
la délégation aux droits des femmes donc
voilà il y a des choses importantes à
porter et on le voit justement les
différences entre les sexes dans la
santé se retrouvent dans tous les champs
la médecine vous avez cité les
pathologies cardiovasculaires et aussi
la question de l'ostéoporose de la
dépression de l'autisme pour ne citer
que ces pathologies mais les différences
en question ne sont pas forcément
d'origine biologique les codes sociaux
de la féminité ou la fragilité la
sensibilité ou de la masculine
masculinité la virilité ou la résistance
au mal influe influence l'expression des
symptômes le rapport au corps et le
recours aux soins de la part des
patients ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes au fil des
siècles le modèle pour penser le corps
humain était largement masculin c'est ce
que Muriel salle vous a expliqué quand
elle a été auditionnée devant votre
délégation elle est historienne et
maîtresse de conférence à l'Université
Claude Bernard de Lyon 1 et elle
dispense l'un des seuls cours sur le
sexe et le genre dans la santé auprès
des étudiants en facultés de médecine à
Lyon nous avons été la rencontrer et je
vous laisse donc l'écouter
et savoir médicaux restent construit
autour d'un principe qu'on appelle
l'androocentrisme voilà c'est à dire que
le corps de référence c'est un corps
masculin et quand on pense les femmes on
pense pas toujours les femmes mais quand
on les pense on les pense en deuxième
intention on y pense comme une exception
à la règle et la règle c'est quand même
le corps masculin on va décrire un
certain nombre de maladies repérés la
prévalence de cette maladie donc le
nombre de personnes qui en soi atteintes
par exemple à partir d'une population
qui a une population masculine et donc
dans certains cas on va définir des
symptômes en disant ça c'est les
symptômes standards par exemple les
symptômes standards de la crise
cardiaque qui sont la douleur dans le
bras gauche une douleur dans la poitrine
enfin voilà en réalité c'est des
symptômes qui sont des symptômes
masculins
quand les femmes présentent une maladie
par exemple une maladie cardiovasculaire
comme elles ont pas les symptômes
standards on dit qu'elles présentent des
symptomatiques les symptomatiques et
c'est un peu comme les exceptions en
grammaire on apprend après avoir appris
la règle et par ailleurs on se souvient
plus souvent de la règle qu'on ne se
souvient de la liste des exceptions donc
ça a des conséquences en termes par
exemple voilà de repérage d'un certain
nombre de maladies et donc cela a des
conséquences très concrètes sur la santé
des femmes avec par exemple les
pathologies cardiovasculaires loin
devant le cancer du sein l'infarctus du
myocarde ou l'accident vasculaire
cérébral représente aujourd'hui la
première cause de mortalité féminine en
France chaque jour 200 femmes vont
mourir d'une pathologie de ce type nous
avons été rencontrés Sabrina layran
Leduc qui a accepté de livrer son
témoignage devant notre caméra
je m'appelle Sabrina j'ai 42 ans
j'habite à zbrouck dans la nuit du 27 au
28 janvier
2021 je me réveille à 3h au matin avec
une douleur très intense entre les
omoplates un inconfort intestinal je
suis un peu comme étourdi avec des
bouffées de chaleur donc au point de
réveiller mon mari parce que je me dis
que je suis pas à l'aise du tout en fait
il pense à ma sœur et une histoire de
Sylvie ou plutôt son décès viennent de
me sauver la vie vu que je suis là à mon
tour victime d'un infarctus du myocarde
lorsqu'il appelle le SAMU Jean-François
le mari de Sabrina va se heurter au
scepticisme du médecin d'abord ces
questions là est-elle angoissée est-elle
stressée à telle porté quelque chose de
lourd
Jean-François insiste on pense vraiment
que ces cardiaque oui mais peut-être que
c'est une crise d'angoisse pourtant j'ai
un mari traitereux très posé et je l'ai
vu envers le SAMU dire non non enfin
c'est cardiaque je reconnais certaines
choses que ma belle-sœur a eu vous
l'emmener en cardiologie et là j'appelle
maman
elle me dit tu es où puce tu es en
retard
et si je suis pas en retard je suis à
l'hôpital
je suis en train de faire un infarctus
elle me dit tu me fais pas ça sinon je
veux pas le faire et elle me dit tu te
bats j'ai dit oui je te promets
[Musique]
et effectivement Sabrina s'est battue et
aujourd'hui elle a réussi à s'en sortir
elle garde des séquelles mais elle va
alerter pour faire connaître le les
symptômes de l'infarctus chez la femme
car aujourd'hui le coeur des femmes est
victime de stéréotypes on l'a vu dans le
récit de Sabrina
aujourd'hui c'est le l'infarctus biocard
reste trop souvent considérée comme une
maladie d'hommes quinquagénaire fumeur
bedonnant et stressé au travail pour des
symptômes identiques de troubles
cardiaques les symptômes des femmes ont
trois fois plus de chances d'être
attribués à des raisons émotionnelles
puisqu'à des causes biologiques Laurence
Cohen comment faire aujourd'hui pour que
la santé des femmes soit
correctement prise en charge pour
qu'elle soit écoutée quand elles vont
consulter leur médecin
quelles sont les pistes de réflexion que
vous pouvez mettre d'abord je veux
rendre hommage au conseil à l'égalité
parce que comme vous l'avez souligné ils
ont fait un gros travail sur cette
question et ils ont fait des
recommandations qui serait nécessaire de
suivre et nous-mêmes au niveau de la
délégation aux droits des femmes avec
mes trois collègues Annick Jacquemin
Marie-Pierre Richer et Laurence
Rossignol on travaille bien sûr avec la
présidente de la commission Annick
billon on travaille sur un rapport qui
sera rendu en juillet pour faire des
recommandations et parmi les
recommandations il y a vraiment
nécessité de formation au niveau des
études de médecine des personnels
médicaux paramédicaux d'ailleurs il y a
aussi une nécessité au niveau de l'école
d'avoir tout un travail aussi de
déconstruction des stéréotypes de aussi
de formation sur les questions de santé
pour montrer les choses et puis il y a
un travail aussi très important à faire
au niveau des entreprises parce que là
c'est tout à fait
sous-estimé avec une médecine du travail
qui n'a pas les moyens aussi de
fonctionner il faut le dire et il faut
le redire donc tout ça doit faire partie
de nous recommandations et c'est ce sur
quoi nous nous planchons en ce moment
qui peuvent aller jusqu'où parce que ce
qu'on comprend dans le reportage c'est
qu'il y a une formation médecine qui est
jeanrée il y a des maladies d'hommes il
y a des maladies de femmes or on voit
que ce n'est pas le cas est-ce qu'il
faut rendre obligatoire dans les écoles
de médecine une formation aux inégalités
de gens tout à fait vous avez raison et
c'est pour ça qu'au début en commençant
notre propos c'est vrai que c'est
important de dire qu'on est dans une
société patriarcale et que c'est ça qui
en fait induit les comportements les
formations et que c'est ça qu'il faut en
quelque sorte des tricoter pour
complètement changer de regard et avoir
un regard qui prend en compte le sexe et
le genre au niveau de la santé mais vous
savez on ne peut pas tout dire ce matin
parce que il faudrait beaucoup de temps
puis il faut regarder le reportage
excellent qui a qui a été fait mais je
pense quand même que par exemple
aujourd'hui une femme enceinte c'est pas
pathologique être enceinte bon si tu as
un bonheur c'est une joie etc mais dans
une entreprise c'est considéré comme un
poids un problème qu'il faut régler
alors que ça n'est pas un point un
problème et il y a pas d'accompagnement
regardez aussi les femmes qui sont dans
un parcours de d'infertilité combien
c'est difficile périlleux voilà il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à modifier à
changer et en en parlant en faisant en
sorte qu'il y ait des rapports
parlementaires qu'il y ait des
recommandations qui est des reportages
comme vous faites je pense aussi que
c'est aider à la prise de conscience
collective de cette on va parler de la
question du travail puisque vous avez
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus et c'est un
des angles du reportage mais sur les
pistes est-ce qu'il faut aussi mieux
former les femmes à l'autodiagnostic à
connaître les symptômes par exemple
c'est le cas dans un infarctus Flora
dans son reportage je dis que les femmes
appellent les secours en moyenne 15
minutes plus tard que les hommes est-ce
que là aussi il y a quelque chose à
faire bien sûr il y a quelque chose à
faire mais c'est toujours aussi dans la
façon dont
les rapports sont construits
c'est-à-dire qu'en général les femmes
vont moins prêter attention à elle-même
elles vont d'abord être protectrices par
rapport à l'environnement et seulement
en second point s'intéresser à elle donc
quand elles vont avoir des symptômes
elles vont les sous-estimer en disant
que finalement ça va se passer c'est pas
grave il faut qu'elle se calme il faut
qu'elle prenne sur elle mais là encore
c'est une image qui est renvoyée dans la
construction finalement du rôle des
femmes dans la société donc c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'à la fois il y a à
travailler au niveau effectivement des
études de médecine mais il y a aussi à
travailler dès le plus jeune âge à
l'école sur les stéréotypes de genre
pour permettre à chacun et à chacune de
bien s'épanouir dans la société en
prenant en compte les différences une
autre pathologie qui est emblématique
c'est l'endométriose qui touche une
femme sur 10 aujourd'hui en France
aujourd'hui petit à petit on prend
conscience de cette pathologie certaines
communes certaines entreprises ont mis
en place un congé menstruel je vous
propose d'écouter nous avons rencontré
Marina Dano je vous propose de l'écouter
ça a commencé à mes 14 ans de mes règles
j'ai été pliée en deux
en 2014 ça a été le début de l'enfer
j'étais à table avec une vingtaine de
potes et d'un coup je sentais plus mon
dos nuage en droite donc rendez-vous
médecin en urgence et puis le médecin il
me dit oh c'est une cruralgie
t'attend ça va passer sauf qu'au bout de
deux mois ça passait pas il y avait pas
d'amélioration je suis parti voir une
ostéopathe en me disant ça a peut-être
m'aider un peu juste ça me regardait en
touchant et me dit mais tu sors d'ici tu
as une énorme ressort dans le ventre je
suis arrivé aux urgences
clairement l'interne il m'a regardé il
m'a rayonné et c'était vos douleurs
c'est des règles et puis votre grosseur
je la sens pas
je suis tombé sur une spécialiste dans
un étriose elle m'a ausculté dans la
foulée à sentier trois nodules elle a
hurlé dans son cabinet en lisant non
mais vous êtes au pire stade de la
maladie et personne n'a rien fait depuis
un an et demi le fait que ce soit une
maladie qui touche que les femmes c'est
beaucoup moins connu j'ai pas envie que
les femmes aujourd'hui elles connaissent
que moi j'ai vécu et surtout pas les
générations à venir
du coup on faire on va aller faire une
photo de groupe un endroit où il y a
plus d'espace et après c'est parti pour
le départ ce matin là Marina organise
une marche contre l'endométriose on
compte 7 ans en moyenne pour parvenir à
un diagnostic un délai qui n'est pas en
conséquence sur la vie des femmes
touchées par cette pathologie il a fallu
que je change de métier
parce qu'en étant assistant de
vétérinaire du coup on se faisait des
grosses opérations qui pouvaient durer
quatre à six heures et debout c'était
juste trop compliqué donc il a fallu que
je revois sur un poste assis et
pas trop physique dans 30% des cas
l'endométriose est synonyme
d'infertilité
donc en moyenne il faut sept ans pour
diagnostiquer une endométriose
aujourd'hui il y a un congé menstruel
qui existe pour les femmes atteintes de
cette pathologie est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à la généralisation de ce
congé mensuel écoutez en tout cas je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait une
réflexion au niveau de ce congé et il
faut faire en sorte aussi que les femmes
ne soient pas discriminées au niveau du
travail donc il faut pas que par exemple
elle puisse être obligé de dire les
raisons de leurs congés c'est ça aussi
qui m'est revenu dans les dialogues que
j'ai pu avoir avec les femmes c'est à la
fois elles veulent un congé mais elles
ne veulent pas être mise en quelque
sorte à l'index de l'entreprise donc
comment est-ce qu'on travaille cette
chose là je pense qu'il y a besoin d'y
réfléchir et de voir concrètement
comment dans le cas
comment on protège les femmes
c'est-à-dire avoir simplement pas
obligatoirement l'appeler quand j'ai
menstruel ça peut être un congé
qui va être mensuel mais sans donner les
raisons de même on est un peu sur c'est
pas la même chose mais tout à l'heure je
pensais à l'accompagnement des femmes
par rapport à leur parcours sur
l'infertilité on a rencontré aussi donc
à Créteil Nathalie Massin qui travaille
sur cette question-là qui ont donc
rhinologue et là encore il y a besoin
elle nous dit que les femmes puissent
s'absenter parce qu'il y a énormément de
rendez-vous qui sont à la fois très
réguliers mais qui ne peuvent pas être
anticipées donc là encore comment est-ce
qu'on peut les accompagner sans que
c'est des conséquences négatives par
rapport à leur carrière professionnelle
c'est ce qui faut voir c'est pour ça que
je dis que il y a un gros travail à
faire au niveau de l'entreprise pour
permettre aux femmes de continuer à
travailler dans de bonnes conditions
d'être accompagné mais sans subir des
discriminations et là je pense que c'est
pas gagné mais vous pensez mais c'est
une action vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui la
prise de conscience est là ou pas encore
alors la prise de conscience à
l'entreprise je pense qu'elle n'est
absolument pas là puisque on le disait
il y a très peu d'entreprises qui ont
vraiment des plans pour accompagner les
femmes et en général c'est je vous dis
c'est sous-évalué et bon on veut pas
s'embarrasser de femmes qui vont avoir
qui vont avoir des problèmes regardez
aussi les femmes et ça touche toutes les
catégories qui tentent à avoir des
enfants pour protéger leur carrière et
puis vous avez quand même une donnée qui
me semble extrêmement importante c'est
les femmes font partie des catégories
des travailleurs les plus les plus
pauvres se sont elles qui sont
majoritairement les plus précarisées
donc on va avoir aussi dans les couches
par exemple comme l'entretien etc des
femmes qui sont particulièrement
exposées au polluants et ça c'est
sous-estimer tous les cancers qui en
découlent vont être sous-estimés de même
que le travail de nuit vous voyez il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et on voit
bien qu'il y a à changer les mentalités
et à imposer au niveau de l'entreprise
des réels protections accompagnement des
femmes sans qu'elles soient considérées
comme étant coupable ce ne sont pas
elles les coupables c'est
l'environnement ce sont les structures
et les conditions de travail de
pénibilité qui sont qui sont
responsables donc c'est ça qu'il faut
changer et on espère que votre travaux
vont contribuer à améliorer cette prise
de conscience et le reportage de Flora
qui est à voir santé des femmes une
inégalité
ignorer c'est avoir vendredi à 16h30 sur
notre antenne et sur notre plateforme
public sénat.fr merci Flora merci merci
beaucoup pour ce reportage un dernier
mot Laurence Cohen puisqu'il y a des
sénatoriales en septembre votre
département fait partie des départements
renouvelables est-ce que vous serez
candidat à votre succession non je ne
suis plus candidate au sénatorial je
suis sénatrice depuis 2011 c'est
passionnant mais là je pense que c'est
le moment de faire autre chose de
tourner la page mais je ne quitte pas
l'activité politique j'ai des
responsabilités en politique au niveau
international notamment sur l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes dans mon
parti le Parti communiste depuis les
années 2000 je suis engagée en politique
depuis bien plus bien plus longtemps
donc tout ça je vais le conserver je
vais me battre contre les sociétés la
société telle qu'elle est avec le
capitalisme le patriarcat qui pour moi
oppresse les individus et singulièrement
les femmes donc ce travail je vais le
poursuivre mais je ne serai pas je ne
serai plus sénatrice à partir du 1er
octobre et puis j'ai eu des mandats
électifs comme cancer régional donc
voilà j'ai une activité riche et
maintenant je pense que c'est bien de
faire autre chose est-ce qu'il y aura
une liste commune du coup dans votre
département et est-ce que Laurence
Rossignol qui est actuellement sénatrice
de l'Oise pour être sur cette liste
écoutez moi je suis extrêmement
tranquille parce que c'est pas ce
qu'elle savait le délit qui prend la
relève et qui est le candidat présenté
par le Parti communiste mais c'est un
candidat qui est un candidat de
rassemblement j'y tiens beaucoup on
était tous les deux
élus depuis
2017 et là il prend la relève en tant
que en tant que tête de tête de Lise
donc il a vraiment cette conviction il
est bien ancré dans le département après
moi je laisse les autres forces de
gauche choisis leurs candidate et leur
et leur candidats donc je n'ai pas de
commentaires à faire si ce n'est que je
travaille très bien avec Laurence
Rossignol comme vous le savez et vous
regretterez qu'elle quitte le Sénat
alors à titre à titre mais s'emmêler là
encore des des décisions des appareils
politiques je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui apporte au Sénat après il faut que
elle choisisse et que son sa famille
politique choisisse mais surtout moi je
tiens à dire que il faut que les
politiques se rassemblent c'est la belle
leçon qu'on donnait les syndicats et si
on veut faire reculer les réformes qui
sont négatives il faut être ensemble
rassemblés et on va en reparler tout de
suite de cette question avec Eric
Coquerel qui va nous rejoindre vous
reviendrez nous voir avant de quitter le
Sénat notamment pour la remise de votre
apport tout à fait je reviens autant de
fois que vous voulez avant l'été
celui-là il sous la pénurie de
médicaments aussi deux rapports dont on
parlera avec vous merci beaucoup
Laurence quand même merci d'avoir été
notre invité dans 20 minutes on
reviendra sur la bataille politique
autour du texte sur l'abrogation de la
réforme des retraites on en parle tout
de suite avec Eric Coquerel